you don't really have to be doing
anything until you're 30 like I know in
your Doogie Howser world you have to
graduate with honors that's 16 otherwise
there's gonna be an issue but okay and
welcome it is today's Sunday special
with Adam Carolla we're gonna jump in in
just a second first I wanna say thanks
to our sponsors over at expressvpn so
with all the recent news about data
hacks and breaches it is very hard for
me not to worry about my digital privacy
because no matter what you do online
your mobile carrier your internet
service provider they track it all every
website you visit every email you send
so that's why I decided to take back my
privacy by using expressvpn these days I
don't use the internet without it
expressvpn as the world's leading VPN
provider it lets you securely use the
internet without being tracked by anyone
which is pretty great especially if
you're a prominent personage like myself
and you're afraid that people are gonna
be grabbing your info expressvpn keeps
my online activity private anonymous
while I browse email download or stream
expressvpn is great for streaming
content you can even use it to watch the
World Cup without a cable subscription
which is pretty awesome if that's the
sort of thing that you are into and you
like that sort of sport they're easy to
use app encrypts all my internet data
hides my IP address protecting my entire
connection and expressvpn cost less than
seven bucks a month that runs seamlessly
and seamlessly in the background of the
computer the phone the tablet every time
you use the internet without expressvpn
you are putting sensitive data at risk
so take back your internet privacy today
find out how you can get three months
for free go to expressvpn comm slash Ben
that is expr ESS VPN comm slash been for
three months free with a one-year
package again visit expressvpn dot-com
slash Ben to learn more
well Adam Carolla thanks for joining me
on Sunday special
my pleasure sure is a pleasure to see
that the founder and creator of the
pirate community I mean so Adam Carolla
for those who don't know created
essentially the podcast medium I mean it
was really Adam who well you did I mean
there are other podcasts out there but
Adams the guy who actually made podcasts
anything where people could support
themselves and have a living doing it
yeah maybe yeah there were others but
yeah I was probably the first one sort
of independently to figure out a way to
do it without maybe a parent company
like NPR or ESPN or something okay I'm
gonna talk about exactly how you came to
do that
I want to start by talking a little bit
about your upbringing because you're
really eclectic dude I mean you have the
podcast you make a documentary now with
Dennis Prager
about bias on college campuses you
didn't go to college you aren't really
overtly conservative you're more just a
common sense guy yeah so where did where
did you come from I mean you're now
listened to by my where's million people
per episode right it means I was no
wheezed out of a bar rag that's where I
came from and I grew up in North
Hollywood California which you know has
a word Hollywood in it but couldn't be
any further than Hollywood it was like
from Hollywood like everyone smiled be
like I saw Robert Urich in the parking
lot of acquittees oh my god you know and
like there's like weird things like that
but really no celebrities
I grew up food stamps and Welfare and a
kind of disjointed family where we got
stuff for free from my grandparents and
the end the man and I kind of quickly I
I got a a quick lesson in how that works
like so I grew up in North Hollywood my
grandparents had a house in North
Hollywood
these are one-bedroom one-bath house is
like 900 square foot houses and the
second house they bought in the 50s for
literally like ten thousand dollars we
got to live at because my mom was not
doing very well and my parents got
divorced and so on and so forth
and so we sort of got a free house so
even though nobody had a job and nobody
had any money we lived in a house versus
an apartment because my grandparents
sort of took pity on their daughter and
let us squat in this house and I like
the first thing I figured out is the
reason the house was always a mess and
the reason it was always falling apart
the shovel and everything else is
because there was no ownership like and
she shouldn't have been living in a
house we should have been an apartment
somewhere or in a van so we lived in
this house and the house just kind of
came undone because again you hand
somebody something for free
and it just starts
I'm done and then it was like food
stamps and Welfare and whatever free
like literally spaghetti night at the
church go to the church like whatever we
could get free lunch programs at the
school with the tickets and the
breakfast programs like all the programs
all the freebies all or whatever and I
just kind of member thinking like I felt
like my family was sort of hobbled
because they got just enough to get by
and not be really motivated so they just
kind of existed what about your white
privilege I mean I mean icing on what
time is it X I'm still they keep saying
they still at luck it's it's insane
because what's insane with with me is I
do think there is a kind of a weird
there is a kind of a prejudice or like
an assumed prejudice when people go well
I Adam come on you're well-spoken you're
white guy you drive a nice car you went
to college like like I would say like I
will say to people I went to North
Hollywood High I graduated North
Hollywood High I start cleaning carpets
up the street literally it aim be carpet
cleaning and and then I got into
construction when I say got into
construction I showed up on a job site
and pull the IV off the side of a house
and so we're like then dragged it up to
the dumpster I dug ditches I literally
dug ditches I picked up garbage and
that's all I did
and they'd go well would you do after
college you're not listening
no college no SATs no algae I never took
an algebra class I took high school math
dumb I was I looked at my transcript the
other day I came in at North Hollywood
High out of my graduating class of 570 I
came in for 97 and I know 30 of those
kids move to Phoenix or died or like
both like that literally like almost out
of 500 kids I came up for seven for 97
so I was a horrible student and even
when I tried I was a horrible student
and then I just got pushed out into the
world that just sort of had to make
do and in terms of the white privilege I
worked the this notion of like hey these
are jobs Americans won't do when I did
carpet cleaning which is the lowest form
of like manual labor like literally get
into a van drive to a colony kitchen or
Tony Roma's or whatever in the in the
middle of the night and just get the
steamer out and steam the entire one and
clean the entire restaurant and then go
back at 4:00 in the morning drop the van
off and go go home and get paid six
bucks an hour I did that originally with
Chris Boehm white guy railed hopper
super white guy Todd oiler Jewish guy
will the Willie Maldonado like Italian
and or Jewish guy and Adam Carolla those
were the five white folks that work for
a and B carpet in the 80s when we're
cleaning carpet and then later on when I
got to a construction site
there were Latin guys and then there was
me and other white guys we're just poor
that the the thing is like whenever
someone goes like who's gonna pick your
lettuce or who's gonna dig that ditch or
who's gonna clean your carpets or who's
gonna bust those trays like poor people
I knew a lot of poor people so where did
you get the work ethic from it sounds
like your mom wasn't big into it and yet
you're somebody who was working hard
basically from the time that you left
high school and I know you're into
football when you're in high school as
well yeah it I learned my work ethic
from sports probably football which was
a really hard taxing sort of hot you
know like I learned
football will teach you discomfort and
how to kind of tolerate discomfort
because when you're in the San Fernando
Valley and you're running you're doing
two-a-days in early September and it's
brutal outside and they think water is
bad for your like just rinse don't you
know literally like spit it out you'll
cramp up like I'm deeply pleased and
you're just running wind sprints in like
full full gear it's crazy it's kind it's
like the mill
Terry so I probably learned that but
later on I just learned that I had to
use my back to make money so I didn't
have any kind of there was no path
intellectually to get paid so if I was
gonna get paid it was it was gonna be
because there was a stack of drywall
over there and you needed that stack of
drywall moved over there and that's how
I got paid and and and in literally
digging ditches and just demoing out
stucco and hauling garbage you know like
that that's all I did
I had jobs where I just get dropped off
at the pier 1 imports now on Wilshire
and Santa Monica we built it a million
years ago and there's just a huge pile
of dirt like like size of like two
minivans and they gave me a shovel the
wheelbarrow and they're like the
dumpsters over there and they're like
however long it takes you to get that
into that then you can leave and I was
just alone just like all day just scoop
you know one load at a time like
counting my steps and trying not to go
insane but anyway as someone whom once
picked up an object that sounds terrible
with me yeah I could definitely this
would not be in the Shapiro wheelhouse
in 1996 ben shapiro picked up a feather
duster and handed it to one of his
Squires
but that's still valid is yeah they have
some manual labor in the Jewish
community right oh oh yeah yeah that's
funny because there are no Jews on the
construction site ever which always is
something that is funny because when I
did construction all throughout the San
Fernando Valley I'd be in Chatsworth in
Canoga Park Simi Valley buh-buh-buh no
one ever said to me you're Jewish right
cuz I could go either way I got atom
right I got the chief Roe I would
complain a lot you know they're like
what that guy but no one it was I was
definitely Italian or or just a non Jew
when I got out of construction and got
into writing comedy it's like well
you're Jewish you know right like no I'm
not sure they're like
I've never I was never mistaken for a
Geo on a construction site and I've
never mistaken for a in a writers
room it just just goes to show you like
you tell people you know you tell people
hey don't stereotype well they're just
playing the odds zero Jews on a
construction site zero
you know in a in a with this hair
in in a writers room it's like they're
trying to save time I learned how to
work hard like working construction and
it was like and but I also learned like
I don't want to get paid by the hour
because I remember having these like
fantasies right I was like going well
you're getting $8 an hour now you know
and your job you're playing to see if we
can work 50 maybe 60 hours a week and
and like pay your bills with your
roommates and your apartments and stuff
like that but I was like even if you got
paid I'd probably think of some princely
sum like $18 an hour or $22 no look even
if you got paid let's just say $25 an
hour it still would be by the hour
like you'd still have to be here on this
jobsite that you don't want to be on so
it's it started I started thinking early
maybe they buy the our way isn't that
isn't the way to go and so how did you
get from doing that to comedy I mean
that's a pretty radical shift from yeah
as you say being the person who is
slepping wheelbarrows full of dirt
places to being in writers rooms on
comedy how did you how did you actually
do that I like sat down in my apartment
when I was like 22 and I'd been doing
labor for you know like labor and
carpentry for maybe three years and I
was driving like a beat-up old mini
pickup truck with like no headrests and
stuff and like I didn't have insurance
and and I wasn't construction it's very
like day labor kind of stuff like it's
like you don't get paid on Christmas if
it rains you don't go to work you don't
get paid that day like literally if you
rolled your ankle playing
sketball on a Sunday you couldn't go in
they wouldn't care but they're not you
don't get paid like that you wouldn't
have to call anyone and go like I'm not
gonna be here they just really like
don't be here just don't get paid we
won't pay like if you left at lunch time
and did half a day you just have 34
hours on your on your timecard look and
I was like huh that sucks like how are
you gonna own a house how are you gonna
pay mortgage how you even gonna get
credit I didn't have credit or anything
like everything was kind of under the
table or whatever it was it was like
catches catch-can and I just like it's
gonna be a long uncomfortable life and
your family's not in the equation in
terms of like no one's gonna leave your
business or your your grandfather's
collection of dues and burgers they'll
be all yours you'll be the selamat
auction and live comfortably like there
was no one had anything no one's gonna
help so I was like 22 23 was in my
apartment with no air conditioning in
north how it might like three roommates
like a one-bedroom and I was like all
right so what what's the plan what what
could possibly be the plan and the one
plan was like well get your contractor's
license and get a better truck and and
maybe get a crew or something like that
I was just like yeah but that's still
tough and it's a lot of work and you get
your tools ripped off and it's just it's
a tough life any and you don't get paid
that much and so I was like all right so
what else do you do and I was like well
you're funny like so you're good with
your hands and then you're funny
so I was like trying to think of things
like sort of practically even though
comedy doesn't sound very practical and
it doesn't sound like a high percentage
sort of job to go into but I knew
anything that involved studying or
training or test-taking that wouldn't
work like it was not gonna be us go
you'll be a dental hygienist you know
it's like I would never be able to pull
that off so I was like you are good at
calming now I don't even know what that
means it just means I was good at comedy
like people are good with their hands
but you still have to learn a skill
a trade you know otherwise being just
good with your hands does not mean you
can read plans and build a house so I
was like okay so what's the plan and the
plan was you're 22 you don't really have
to be doing anything until you're 30 in
in my world like I know in your Doogie
Howser world you have to graduate with
honors that's 16 otherwise there's gonna
be an issue but for me I was like when
you're 30 you must become a man that was
my like Bar Mitzvah like I was like I
think you can screw around no one really
thinks you're a loser when you're
screwing around in your 20s but at a 30
I want to be doing something but my goal
was don't put the pressure on yourself
you have like eight years to figure out
this thing called comedy and don't even
put the pressure on yourself which is
when you're you know 30 you got to be on
TV
you have to have your own show or you
have to be syndicated radio host there I
didn't have any of that I just had right
now you're making money off your back
could you make money off of your ideas
or something that involves some air
conditioning like I just wanted some air
conditioning like it's when it gets hot
and you just eat you sit on a pile of
drywall and it's like it gets brutal in
my entire life yeah yeah and so I was
just like I would be happy working for a
greeting card company if we were in a
room and there are three people pitching
funny Father's Day cards and I could
like come up with some funny ideas you
know that that was about it like I was
like I didn't have the bar too high but
I needed to be doing something that had
dental insurance or something and so I
just said well what he got to do and
somebody said we'll take a Groundlings
class and you could go to The
Groundlings and like learn how to do
improvisational comedy and get up on
stage and do group comedy and sketches
and like write stuff down
stuff like that I was like okay so here
I was like with literally with no car
insurance and no medical or dental
insurance or anything just living
hand-to-mouth and but I paid like 275
bucks for a Groundlings class you know
and and I was like going out on Sunday
nights and just doing open mics at
waiting in line and stuff like that and
everyone in my world was kind of like
are you nuts like what are you paying
for like we're going out Sunday night or
whatever we're getting some beers were
going to the park you know whatever and
I'd be like I'm going to go wait in line
at rooster T feathers to do a
three-minute set you know and no one's
like are you high and and I was like I
don't know what I'm doing but I know I
have to do this thing over here and but
I stuff to work full time in this very
different world which is construction
and so how did you get from doing you
know three-minute comedy sets to then
doing what you're doing now cuz that's a
pretty large jump that a lot of folks in
LA who are doing we're in line with you
yeah who are now probably managing
coffee bean yeah we're not doing exactly
what you're doing no I know and then I
cursed those people and the reason I
cursed them is because many nights I
would go out and it like hey we're
cutting it off at 40 people like and or
40 or 50 people would show up and they'd
go only 18 are getting up onstage so put
your name and a hat the guy pulled the
name out and I wouldn't make it and I
realized if you are doing something and
you shouldn't be doing it you're
possibly preventing other people who
should be doing it from doing it so it's
like I didn't get up on stage that night
because the guy who's managing the
coffee bean did get up on stage I so I I
was I I was plugging around for like
eight years
and and I was doing stand-up and I still
in sketch and I was doing like well
acting and I see a little writing and I
said like little bits and pieces of
miniature success and
I'd also at that time got into teaching
boxing for a living because not for a
living
I taught morning classes at a place
called bodies in motion
I teach like the 7:00 a.m. class of a
6:30 a.m. class and it's getting like 20
bucks a class or something but it was
boxing was just another story sometimes
into and blah blah blah but it was part
of me kind of going as you get to 30 and
as the comedy dream isn't really coming
to fruition the doing something where
you're on your feet where you're
interacting with people where you're
talking to people construction would be
lonely like you just go there and you
just go you'd work alone a lot of times
just be sitting in some half-finished
house and Simi Valley just putting in
molding or base shoe or crown or
whatever it is all day and like I was
kind of like I want to talk I want ideas
I want a clown I want to you know make
people laugh and whatever and so when I
was teaching my boxing classes you get
these 20 people and you get to kind of
conduct and lead and like I taught
comedy traffic school for the same
reason like I don't care about traffic
school but I want to be on my feet I
want to be telling jokes and I want to
be whatever so it's doing all these
things and so while I was I would teach
boxing in the morning and then I would
go do my carpentry at that point I just
worked for myself like I said clients
and I just build cabinets or whatever
that's kind of getting by and and I was
driving my truck over the hill with
somebody's entertainment unit in the in
the back and it was a it was a very it's
kind of a haunting thing and I'll tell
you why because just to come full circle
here so I'm driving over the hill and
I'm going to a woman named Marjorie
Grossman's house probably Jewish and she
is writing for Seinfeld she has a job
writing for Seinfeld and she heard about
me and she just bought her first house
on the west side and putting in I'm
gonna build her an entertainment unit
blah blah blah
and so I literally called from her house
as I'm driving over the hill I'm
listening to Kay rock radio I'm
listening to Kevin and bean I'm
listening to Jimmy the sports guy who's
now Jimmy Kimmel back then like third
banana on the morning show getting into
an argument with Michael the maintenance
man and next thing you know we're gonna
have a boxing match between Michael the
maintenance man and Jimmy the sports guy
I didn't know either one of them
obviously I'm like a person that's
listening to the radio you know and I
get to Marjorie Grossman's house and I'm
like could I use your phone and I'm
calling k-rock going hey I'm a boxing
trainer cuz they put it out there like
we need trainers we need a venue we need
equipment and I'm like I could train now
it was so funny cuz everyone assumes I
wanted to train Jimmy but I didn't
because Jimmy had just got to the radio
station he was there like for three or
four weeks Michael a maintenance man had
been there for a number of years was
kind of a fixture also Michael was black
and I was just playing the odds like he
did on the construction site and the
writers room is just gonna say give me
the brother I bet he's got a little more
ability in that ring and so I didn't
want it trained I'll take either one of
them but I it wasn't like I was just
calling from Marjorie's house going oh
hey I'll hold you know and like like
leaving a message hey this is Frank
Murphy got a producer of the morning
show this never called back like 100ms
I'd be and I remember also I was talking
to Marjorie and she's like yeah I write
for Seinfeld Oh how does it work it's
like well we get into a big room you
know and we order some Chinese food I'm
like who pays for the Chinese I don't
know but you don't have to pay for it I
know like someone else pays for the
Chinese it yeah or we could get Italian
but every day yeah okay because on the
construction site was always like oh who
is the lunch truck money you know so
it's like yeah we just start spitballing
ideas and then we have a big dry erase
board
and you're getting like thousands of
dollars a week for eating Chinese food
and spitballing ideas and I was like oh
and I remember thinking like you got it
made you got it made oh so I was
building our thing and I kept calling
k-rock and they kept not answering and
then like the next day I would I would I
would get I would hear him again on the
radio like hey we're looking for
trainers and they interviewed like a
trainer on the phone like hey we got a
trainer on the phone and I'd be like no
no no it's me I'll be the trainer I'll
be the trainer and at some point I
realized I need to show up at k-rock
because nobody's I didn't have a
cellphone you know I've had to go use
Margery Grossman's phones and no one was
and I had to go to the building I found
out where the building was in Burbank
and I showed up before my class at like
6:00 a.m. and I got into the lobby but
the building was closed like I couldn't
go up the elevator to k-rock or whatever
and I was like they're like yeah the
elevators don't start going till 7:00 or
something so I went and taught my class
and the next day I got a guy named tree
who uh good name and last name a round
tree nickname tree that's a boxing coach
so I got a tree to cover my class and I
went back at seven and I got up the
elevator to the ninth floor where k-rock
was like commercial building but k-rock
was locked like a rock didn't open until
9:00 for business so now I'm just
standing in the halls of the ninth floor
of a commercial building in Burbank by
the elevators and I'm like that they
don't show up till 9:00 the morning
shows on but they're like tucked away in
the corner and it'd be like you and I
sitting here and someone just standing
out in the lobby who couldn't get up
here so I just stood there like I was
just like where should I go what should
I do and I stood there and some guy came
up the elevator
and he clearly like had like a hand
truck or something he had business like
he was dropping off some stuff and he
was walking around
back although I go in what is now I know
is the back door of k-rock with the
keypad or whatever and I was like
following him like are you going into
k-rock and there he's like yeah you know
I'm filling the vending machine or
something and I was like could you tell
them there's a boxing coach waiting by
the elevators and I'll just wait by the
elevator should go tell anyone in there
there's a boxing coach and he's like
yeah alright and he said went in and I
just stood by the elevator for like 20
minutes or something and at some point
Jimmy just came down the hall same
direction the guy went and he just kind
of walked up to me it was probably in
doing the morning show he's probably in
the middle of doing the show and he's
like are you the boxing coach and I said
yeah and he said ok and it's like I
could be your boxing coach and he's like
yeah ok ok he's like I like when you
want to start he's like I don't know
today later today
after I'm done and I'm like yeah yeah
let's start like how about noon at
bodies in motion and Pasadena like ok
I'll meet you the parking lot you know
and I just stood there and like the
parking structure and he pulled up in a
beat-up rx-7 like it was really beat on
and that's like my Isuzu Troopers nicer
than I remember Lincoln hmm what if I
went in on this but I was like I got
three weeks to train this guy and all I
want to do is pick his brain about how
he got into radio and how he got into
comedy now he's not high up the food
chain at k-rock right so he's kind of
does some writing does some producing
does some editing and does the sports
bed but he's not Kevin or being or Frank
Murphy the producer so he's not gonna be
able to march in there and go hey fellas
new plan this guy's you know like is
nothing so but but we just keep talking
about comedy and comedy comedy county he
kind of realizes that I have some some
ability beyond boxing for for comedy and
he does the fight he loses the fight
they sent him out for the second round
with no mouthpiece I remember
so after the fight he goes well like now
we're kind of done you know and I was
like yeah well what could I do you know
and he said he said well what do you
what do you do like what do you want to
do and I was like I don't really know
and I said well what I do is is I hang
out a crack wise fast on my feet and I
just kind of roll with it and he said
yeah Kevin him being that's their job
they don't need you doing that so I was
like well what could I do and he said
come up with a character and you could
call in like Monday morning and it's
probably never gonna work and they'll
never want to hear it again but that's
the only shot you got and I was like I
don't really do characters and he's like
well come up get to that in one second
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over a policy genius so 71% of
people say they need life insurance the
truth is 100 percent of people need life
insurance because you go and die but
only 59% of people have coverage that
means at least 12% of people are
procrastinating and a lot more people
need it I don't know they need it and
sure procrastinating is normally a bad
thing but if you avoid getting life
insurance then you die then it really is
a bad thing so this is why you should
head over to my friends over at policy
genius well you're putting off getting
life insurance policy genius was making
it easy policy genius is the easy way to
compare life insurance online you can
compare quotes in just five minutes and
when it's that easy
putting it off becomes a lot harder you
can compare quotes while you're sitting
on the couch watching TV or while you're
listening to this podcast and just try
it how C genius has helped over 4
million people shop for insurance
they've placed over 20 billion dollars
in coverage and they don't just make
life insurance easier they also do
disability insurance and renter's
insurance health insurance if you care
about it they can cover it so if you
need life insurance but you've been
putting it off because it's too
confusing or you don't have time
checkout policy genius you have no more
excuses it's the easy way to compare top
insurers and find the best value for you
again no sales pressure zero hassle and
again it's free policy genius.com
when it's this easy to compare life
insurance there's no reason to put it
off go check it out policy genius com
I've checked it out the office it's
great policy genius com
okay so what character did you end up
coming up with for a k-rock III remember
I had the weekend and I was like the
game movie reviewer you know and I
like I don't know like I don't think I
could do that like I'm not I never did
characters so I was like wait a minute I
started thinking like I only has this
thought I've sort of go for what you
know like what do you know and I was
like well I know carpentry really well
and then I was like okay I've always
talked about how every shop teacher ever
had was horrible and like they i rana
CLE like they loved wood but they hated
kids like they hated like they looked at
my shop teachers are like Walter Reed
Elementary looked at the shop is their
shop and we were like fathering that
like what are you doing in my shop but
get away from my table saw it's like
it's not yours old man you're here to
teach us how to use the table saw like
get away from my drill index that's not
to read I go back that's Ryan's middle
school that day
mr. gage and mr. Martin and you know mr.
Hsu Ponzi mr. Walters and it and so
that's like a shop teacher a shop
teacher who taught remedial wood at
Louis past your middle school in
Monrovia and his name was mr. Burch
because Burch is a kind of wood and I
played Pop Warner football with a guy
named birch um and I just thought that's
a cool name and also smells like wood
you know but then I was like why would
mr. Bertram call k-rock in the morning
like what well I was looking I was
approaching it like I was a groundling
you know I was like what is his
motivation for calling k-rock and his
motivation would always be that he was
injured in the shop over the weekend he
wasn't coming in Monday morning school
because I'd call it like 7:15 I'd say I
know all these kids listen to your
crappy music like they love smashing
dumplings and nervosa and all your
crappy hippie music and they're
listening now on their clock radios like
their long block radius I was like let
me yell at them and I would like get in
the phone and I go now listen to me
you're gonna get mr. Hensley he's gonna
come in there with his sweater vest from
home ACK he's gonna substitute so I'd
like make some someday Joe
about him and I go nobody's doing
anything he's gonna fire up the Duquesne
projector we're putting blood on the
bandsaw on you guys are all gonna ride
out the rest of class just put your head
on the desk nobody's touching any tools
or anything and I would go except for
Brad Higgins star like he was there was
always one student they liked and I mean
Brad listen to me Brad like and I'd be
like she'll help me God if I come back
there tomorrow and someone got into my
drill index or my Makita calendar I'm
gonna be ripped you know and and then I
would tell Brad had to like go through
like I think about a dovetail joint but
maybe a finger joint but also I don't
want to do a butt joint Brad let's do a
dado oh no let's do a rabbit but okay
Brad take the dado set up and put it on
the biesemeyer france set up the dado on
the table saw and i just start getting
those like crazy nailing schedule on
sheer wall and and stuff like that and
and the character was huge because
everyone thought he's actually a guy
like yeah and so these two start they'd
have me like come in the studio and like
people call up and go like I want to
make a playhouse for my kid or something
like that and I'd go treated bottom
plate 2x4 16 on center that's your
layout double top plate you know use a
16 penny sinker but don't use for
sinkers when your cheer wall and use
like a 10 penny ring shank cuz sinkers
vinyl codes gonna come out or you could
nail it off with a penny sinkers make
sure it's struck one you know see Deacs
half-inch good one side put the label
african and inspected and I never they
go like how does he know what this stuff
is you know and so people were sort of
intrigued that this guy was like funny
but he also every time someone called in
he they'd go like a roofer came to the
house and he said that some of the metal
on a drip edge no no weep screed yeah
weep screed like like wait a minute how
did you know it
like because I've pictured myself on a
roof and weep screed so it caught on I
got signed by William Morris I became
the sort of local celebrity I
immediately like got offers and and
stuff like that
I got a manager and just the the
bittersweet weird circle this is then
about two years and maybe even a year
and a half and it stuff happened
immediately once I got on a rock he just
happened fast I get this call from my
manager and he's like hey I got a call
from Marjorie Grossman's brother and I
said what why and he said cuz he's he's
getting he's taking getting her Affairs
in order or whatever and I said what
happened I'd of like ovarian cancer a
few months ago that's like oh really
yeah and her brother is going through
all her stuff and her brother wants to
know why there's a check for $1,200 dad
and parola
because her brother knew who Adam
Carolla he's not her she wrote me a
check for Adam coral the comedian but
she wrote a check to Adam Carolla the
carpenter and I remember it was like
literally yesterday I was envying her
life you know Zach aah God you got it
made don't you've got a new house he got
entertainment you're working around and
she just died like that and now I'm like
got my manager and I you know Willie
Morris and blah blah blah and I was like
God life's pretty pretty interesting
tapestry yeah so you end this you ended
up obviously becoming huge on radio and
then eventually you decided to launch a
pirate ship of your own and it's moving
fast forward an hour already
yeah exactly so how did you so how did
that come about how did you decide you
know I'm done with radio I'm not doing
terrestrial anymore now I want to do
this podcasting thing that nobody had
really tried successfully to that point
but you spotted a market before there
even was a market and now the rest of us
gets make a living in it yeah where's my
Vig at least whet might be I'm not the
government but 10% is kind of a standard
it's hiding we all right I never thought
of I've never thought about any
advanced other than move forward like
I'm kind of like you know I've always
kind of looked at it it's like hey we're
in the middle of the ocean look toward
the horizon or look toward wherever you
think land is and just start swimming
and then like somebody would keep saying
like where are you going
or what island you're like I'm shooting
for it I got I'm going I don't know I'm
just I'm just going that way and they'd
go well how do you know there's and I'm
like well the alternative is just kind
of treading water out here until we're
consumed by sharks like so I'm like
let's just let's just go so I always
assumed in radio that I would get thrown
off of radio for saying something stupid
and then I'd go get another job
somewhere else like it was like well
I'll get cut for this team for getting
into it with a coach but I'm a good ball
player and I'll just get picked up by
this other team but I didn't know the
league was gonna collapse and what
happened in oay oh nine with my radio is
sort of the league collapse like there
was no more guys getting paid a lot of
bucks to give their opinions on the FM
side so at all the FM side just
completely went to music and playlists
and no no DJs and somebody figured out
like why are we paying these guys
hundreds of thousands or millions of
dollars to do this when we just do a
program so there was no more work and I
had this I had two young kids and a
pretty good lifestyle in terms of like
mortgage in a warehouse and you know a
couple of cars and like I had a kind of
big monthly nut and no job and I was
getting paid for like nine months to the
end of my contract so I was just like I
did not believe in podcasting per se
because there wasn't any model for
podcasting and in terms of revenue
generation so my thing was like look
after all the work that I did which
would
literally be like go to that apartment
get on the roof and scrape the tar paper
off it I was like that's work talking is
something you do with a friend at lunch
that is one of the most enjoyable
endeavors like what's better than you
having lunch with a guy you just love to
talk to you know like you and I we love
dennis prager
mhm going out to dinner with dennis
prager that's two hours of talk but
that's you'd pay for that so I was like
I never want to look at talking as a job
so and also to built this audience over
the years and I don't want to have my
tether come unmoored and like float out
somewhere for and then come back and see
if I can get them gathered up and into
the tent again so I was just like well I
knew we had many millions of minutes of
streaming every month but the radio
station and their sort of infinite
wisdom was like they come in and they go
you guys are number five in Los Angeles
you got to get into the top three oh and
he had 19 million minutes of streaming
last month I go well that's good for
something right they go no it's not but
I kept going literally like 19 million
minutes of streaming in a month I'd go
it's got to be something right so that
thought is Wells getting paid for 10
months to stay home essentially I was
like well let's start podcasting and it
really has changed everything I mean
everybody I had Joe Rogan in here a few
weeks ago we were talking about you and
he was crediting you as got the guy who
kind of realized that there was another
continent out there that nobody else
knew was out there and obviously that's
happened for for a huge number of us
it's also created an enormous amount of
Liberty in the space because being on
radio you did bring a lot longer night
abided radio - there's always this fear
that you're gonna say the one thing and
then the one thing will get you fired
and it will finish your career and
Europe for you it's a lot harder cuz
you're in comedy and now I mean I was
gonna ask you this from their beginning
aha
how do you do comedy in an era of
political correctness because it seems
like everybody is getting slaughtered
right now every comedian yeah gets to a
certain point and then denies the Long
Knives just come out if you make the
wrong joke Celeste you are properly woke
or you're you're Amy
Schumer and you're just gonna make a
bunch of feminist jokes or so they can
say whatever you want but if you're
anybody else I mean you're a white dude
who's relatively conservative on
politics or at least is perceived that
way and that means the knives come out
so how do you how do you deal with that
you know it's it's kind of interesting
but I do feel like they do as much as
they think they can get um meaning I've
had plenty of that in my my career I
think if the attitude is I don't
apologize I don't care attacking me is
not gonna be satisfying for you there
needs to be every I was just talking
about this on my five guess which is I
used to fight in the street of a fair
bit not a lot but like I've had
definitely had some street fights and I
knew how to fight and I was just like I
don't know 22 and I was like I would
fight and I always knew I wasn't a mean
person and I would not pick a fight with
anybody but I knew if somebody wanted to
fight I knew exactly how to get them out
into the street with me to fight like we
want to leave this party and we will go
fight I would tell them I don't want to
fight I I don't want I don't want
trouble like I really don't want trouble
and their answer would be oh you found
trouble yeah but I'm really I'm kind of
a mellow guy and and I just I'm sorry if
I stepped on your foot or something
their kitchen but I don't and they'd be
like yeah well this is a bad day for you
and I'd go okay well I guess we gotta
fight and I beat him up but but all I
had to do is take a step or two
backwards and they took two big step
forward if you step forward they don't
step forward they realize it's no it's
it's it's it's it's no fun going after
Adam Carolla it's it's much better
getting this guy fired or that guy fired
this guy that people issue the long
winded sort of crafted by their
publicist apologies and all its like
it's so much better and really all you
do is you just kind of
tell them to shove off a couple of times
and they just kind of go like all right
he's no good
like he's no good because he doesn't
issue these long-winded apology so
there's like that and I I'm also just at
a certain point you will be who you are
like no Howard Stern can say whatever he
wants when everyone said no one ever
demands at Howard Stern apologize
because Howard Stern is Howard Stern mmm
or it's it's my snoop dog can smoke weed
wherever he wants so if I went to like
an AIDS Hospice
I couldn't spark up soup dog could fire
up a hookah pipe in the middle of in a
hospice and they'd be like that's no
that's fine he's he's Snoop Dogg you
know what I mean like he literally can
smoke pot wherever he wants because he's
Snoop Dogg so once you establish
yourself is I'm the person who says
things that offend people they sort of
leave you alone you we've said I've said
a couple times on the show you're not
ostensibly political you found yourself
in this sort of circle where you have
friends on the left obviously like
you're still good friends to Jimmy
Kimmel but then you're also very good
friends with Dennis Prager you and I are
friendly so why is it do you think that
you've been embraced by the right when
you're really sort of you consider
yourself sort of an apolitical dude well
you know it's weird so people say oh
you're conservative your right-wing or
whatever I said well go back and listen
to Loveline the non-political radio show
it from 1997 rod go look Family
Education people shouldn't be having
kids who can't afford kids they need
that the families need to stay together
they need to raise these kids and he did
it at least crazy right-wing
notions now that no one ever thought of
is is political that was political like
wash the whites with the whites and the
colors with the colors like it was just
that's how you do laundry
like this is how you become successful
you stay together you raise your kids
you pay you don't buy things you can't
pay for you don't rely on the government
that government's not gonna do a good
job taking care of you you have to do it
yourself you know delayed gratification
oh whatever all the stuff I learned
through quite frank
this little microcosm called North
Hollywood High was a very interesting
combination of different of different
folks different ethnicities and
different whatever I was in North
Hollywood hi we had the Jewish kids from
Studio City the hills Hebrew heights as
her is called and they would come down
to North Holland I that was their their
high school and you know there was Jeff
buck and Nate Wittenberg and Robbie
Levine and all these kind of guys and
their like their family stayed together
and they were in Student Council and
they did well and their schoolwork and
stuff like that and then there was like
white trash dudes like me from literally
right next to the high school in North
Hollywood my buddy ray and Chris and
stuff like that and then we had some
Mexican guys who were like from little
deeper from the Valiants black guys or
like bussed in from South Central
because I played football with all those
guys and at a certain point when when
when North Hollywood High was was done
as he'd done because like my friends
some of them didn't graduate or they
just moved on or they wandered off and
had jobs the Jewish kids like went off
to UCLA and Stanford and Cal the black
kids just went back to the hood and the
white trash and the Mexican guys hung
out and got jobs digging ditches and so
I was like hmm what's the through line
here and it's like well all my friends
their parents were divorced they were
living in apartments like they weren't
into education there were hands off you
know we didn't we were just sort of
we're house like nobody was doing
homework or you know whatever so I put
together this composite like very
quickly of like what works and what
doesn't work just based on this petri
dish called North Hollywood High and how
these folks went off to be successful
and we went off the toil in the Sun so I
understood that and I always preached it
and it and no one ever accused me of
being political for many of the notions
I had about just sort of self-reliance
you know my mom got welfare and food
stamps and when she was a
and the house was a mess and we barely
got by and it was a war a bad life and
she was like hobbled by and she knows
she doesn't know she's not you know she
doesn't have spina bifida and she's and
she's not a she just never knew
what she could do
just like I never knew what I could do
until the radio station fired me like I
needed to be pushed out and if the radio
state I would have worked there for a
thousand years so all of a sudden these
things have become political stances
which is it's kind of confusing to me
and I'm not really into arguing about
you know who does a better job like look
it's it's also weird world where you
can't speak logically to people like
I've had a million like some of the
stuff I get thrown back in my face it's
like look if something happens to me my
wife I'd like a mom and a dad a male and
a female to raise my kids because we
both offer very different things but
that being said I will take the lesbian
couple or the gay couple who's doing a
little better who has a better minivan
that's a little newer and a little safer
who lives in a better part of town with
a better school system I will take them
over the heterosexual couple if they're
marginally better if everything is
exactly the same this is weird world we
live in it's like everything's the same
I'll give them the male on the female
because traditionally I figured out
through nature that works a little
better and everyone's like oh so you
don't think a gay couple should be able
to raise like no that's not what I said
and then they do this one which is
always insane and I I don't I I wonder
this out loud all the time and I'm gonna
pose this question to you because I
believe I have to be intellectually
honest one of the biggest problems I got
into is when somebody said to me who's
funny or men or women I didn't think I
was allowed to say they're both exactly
the same I had to answer the question I
said men are funnier cuz they're trying
to get laid why so they've all think
about all that all we put into getting
lay but also I said that being said I
know plenty of women that are funnier
and every guy went
I school with but if you're just gonna
ask me I'll go I'll go with men and I
got sent of crap for that but here's
what I don't get
every time I say to somebody look all
things being equal I'll take the
heterosexual couple now the gay couples
doing a little better and their tax
returns and lives in a safe neighborhood
I'll take the gay couple and then they
go alright so you're saying the
heterosexual couple could be strung out
on math and they could the woman is
she's full-time prostitute
he's pimping her out they're cooking up
they're making meth in their bathtub of
their apartment which by the way is in a
very dangerous part of town and the gay
couple
that's David Geffen and he's okay you
would take and I said uh no I think I
was insanely clear I said all things are
the same all things are the same I would
take this but if the other couple then
they go well that's a flawed premise
because you can't make everything the
same and I'm like have the same job live
in the same neighborhood I don't know
some may think one guy likes jeopardy
the other like Desperate Housewives or
something but just make everything the
same would you like now but are these
people stupid like what when they say to
me so you would take this couple that
raises ray be infested raccoons in their
camper and their double-wide over David
Gemmell like no but why did you say that
why would you say like are they insane
are they intellectually dishonest are
they lying like I can't and well they
expect me to go rat oh you caught me
look at it I said the same everything
showed me the same I do think that
they're looking for a a world in which
they're they need an answer and the
answer is always going to be that it's
their political viewpoint or you have a
character flaw and so if you do not
repeat their political viewpoint then it
must be that you have a character flaw
and that character flaw means that
secretly even though you've already said
this stuff secretly you do believe that
the rabies infested double-wide with the
heterosexual couple is better than David
because your secret motivation is that
you like gay people worse than you like
straight people you like straight people
more you like gay people right and so
even if you say all things being equal
deep down in your heart you know
secretly the what this is really coming
from as animus for gay people I think I
think that's really what it is I think
because having spoken with more people
on the left's then anybody that I know
in my lifetime I it's it's it seems to
me that when people are being
intellectually dishonest that way and
you see it with Kathy Newman and Jordan
Peterson for example or Jordan Peterson
is talking about earnings and Kathy
Newman and suddenly just recasting
everything that he's saying right she
knows what he's saying it's just that
she doesn't believe that that's really
his motivation in saying it it's them
attempting to read your heart I think
right and so if you're comfortable it's
it goes back to what you were saying
early if you're comfortable in who you
are it's hard for them to come back at
you because they want to say that you're
homophobic or you're racist or something
you say well I'm not that and they don't
have any place to go from there for them
that's the only place that they can go
because if they they acknowledge that
you have a like I'm sure Jimmy doesn't
say that to you have you said the same
thing because Jimmy knows are a good guy
sure does people who don't know you're a
good guy and who think you're a bad guy
we're gonna in tribute that motivation
to you and Jimmy's as left as it comes
right I mean yeah I mean he has old yes
like old-fashioned values as well which
don't necessarily come out on stage he
definitely is a family man he's super
loyal like he has basic like old-school
traditional I don't know I don't know
what's I don't know what's political
what's not political anymore but he's
very family-oriented
he's more religious than I am and I got
everyone because I'm like it a zero
I got a beat well a he and he's very
loyal and he's very honest like he's has
all the qualities that you would want
the grandparents would want their kids
right now the only point that I'm making
is that he's politically different than
you are but he's not attributing these
bad motivations to you so I would say
that typically and the same thing is
true you know for people who I deal with
I have friends who are on the political
left and if they don't spend their days
misaligning
you know miss attributing character to
me then I know that they're a decent
person like it seems to me that it's
always been about yeah well it's it's
also I think I think part of the I mean
part of the problem I mean I have this
I've always had this sort of theory
which is like all roads lead to
narcissism and if you can hop on the
line on Twitter and say what happened to
Cecil the line as a tragedy and it
should never happen again and it's not
going to happen on my watch or something
then you get to just send out to the
heavens that you're a virtuous person
and the way to so there's two ways like
there's two ways if I make fifty grand a
year there's two ways I can get a raise
one way is work harder and make 75 grand
next year the next way is push you down
from 50 to 25 and thus I just got a
raise and by mine now it's it's a
horrible math and it's not a way it's
not a way to get you yourself any
further down the road but if Ike if I if
my personality if my virtue is a7 and
yours is a7 if I can knock you down to a
three or minus two then guess who gets
me at the top of virtue mountain and
that'll be me so I think a lot of it is
narcissism that's being disguised as as
some sort of you know caring out loud
like caring from the mountaintops like I
was talking to my wife the other day cuz
she's like what's with everybody and
their stupid tweets about you know I
weep for the kids on the border and
stuff like that and it's like it's fine
to be upset about kids on the border but
then go down to the border or or write a
check to one of the many charitable
institutions that are helping this gets
on the board but you don't need to send
it I don't need to know how you feel
about what's going on in the border or
cease a line or anything else and I was
like my last tweet I think my wife got
mad about this but my last tweet was
I've been telling I told everyone don't
do it your kids think but you can whiz
in your sink if you're tall enough sorry
one of the great time savers of life is
like brushing your teeth and wisdom and
nobody tweeted me it turns out you can
save millions of gallons of water and
they're showing this thing where it's
like there's a sink words like you pee
into it and you wash your hands and it
washes to whatever and I tweeted it back
yes I'm a hero
and then somebody tweeted back yeah but
you don't wash your hands so wouldn't
work and I was like true like so I tweet
now I'm coming across like a hero unbent
your periscope but I think my tweet was
a self-deprecating right not here's what
we should do at the border and our
things need to change like it's just I
think a lot of it I think almost all
roads lead to narcissism
in almost every department and this is
why we're hearing so much of this and
then also it was considered sort of
gauche to put your opinions out all the
time for everyone to read you're
virtuous I mean again if you're making
fun yourself for whizzing in the sink
fine zero well is it's always a pleasure
to have Adam Carolla here again the
godfather of podcasting and also a man
with with some great many tips about
where you should whiz so you get that
you get the information and the company
from Hannah girl I'll get you an Apple
box and you can join the perfect thank
you so much it's always what I've been
looking for a damn thing so much for
stopping by
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producers Mathis Glover and Austin
Stevens
edited by Alex Singaram audio is mixed
by micro Amina Terran makeup is by Jess
wahala Vera entitle graphics by Cynthia
and gula the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday
special is a daily wire forward
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018
[Music]